oui là moi je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec ça à beaucoup de niveaux
d'abord dans un premier temps
l'expérience esthétique des séries elle
vient justement elle vient du fait que
c'est une expérience alors il ya d'abord
des éléments y sont similaires à
d'autres formes artistiques et damman le
cinéma parce qu'en fait en réalité vous
trouvez tout à fait des scènes longues
des éléments qui sont en lien avec la
mise en scène et pas seulement des
éléments du scénario je pourrai ainsi un
exemple une série sur laquelle j'ai
beaucoup travaillé qui s'appelle de la
furieuse et avec cette taille là on peut
clairement travailler sur la question de
du temps de de l'inscription une scène
et de l'expérience de là d'un moment
présent et d'autre part en fait on voit
bien dans ce discours là que il ya deux
poids deux mesures en fait c'est à dire
que on peut tout à fait tenir exactement
le même discours sur les armes des
lézardes illégitime c'était en retenir
exactement le même discours sur un
cinéma qui se serait homogénéiser autour
d'éléments commerciaux on peut tenir
exactement le même discours sur la
littérature on peut faire tout ça mais
on ne le fait pas parce que actuellement
on est dans un état où on a ou là le
combat de la légitimation il est sur la
sellette et les îles et sur le jeu vidéo
il est sur certaines choses mais ce soir
c'est un cercle en fait de légitimation
d'art il faut pas confondre en fait le
discours médiatique sur des objets et
les objets eux-mêmes parce que quand on
étudie effectivement ces objets quand on
y regarde on n'a pas du tout c'est la
même expérience que celle qui vient
d'être d'être révoqué en fait celle qui
vient d'être évoquée c'est le discours
médiatique actuel sur les séries et
c'est vraiment de choix tout à fait
différente qu
[Musique]